my name is Michael Kennedy I'm a
professor of sociology and international
studies at Brown University and the
whole summit has been a fascinating
exercise in thinking about how
government leaders corporate leaders and
civil society leaders are able to
collaborate and imagine not just new
solutions to existing problems but even
think about the ways in which we can
rethink what the problems are and I
think one of the most interesting things
for me as an academic is to think about
the place of the university as such as
one of the enterprise's within civil
society within government and within the
corporate sector I just came from a
session on corruption and one of the
things that that suggests is that we
each tend to think about the diagnosis
of corruption and the solution to
corruptions problems mainly through our
own lens and so the ways in which we can
think about how to move beyond our
existing frames it's one of the ways in
which we can make a difference that
here's the key issue how can we think
about corruptions address without
invoking a hypocritical stance this is
the key issue that comes not only from
the discussion here but obviously from
the discussions in the north of Africa
so this is a good start